- Good morning believe nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael
and my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are going
to solve all the world's major problems.
I started the believe life
series to try to expand
beyond just the world of entrepreneurship
and try to learn some other
skills, resources, ideas
to help us become maybe a
more complete human being
So today we're going to learn
how to survive a hangover,
and as always guys, if you
hear something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it down in the comments
below and put quotes
around it so other people
can be inspired, and
when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- I have a question for you.
Tell me if this look is
at all familiar to you.
Why?
If it is, you probably have been hungover.
If it's not, you have
more self control than me
when it comes to alcohol,
and probably a lot of other things.
Don't think too highly of yourself.
That isn't really saying much.
For any of you who've never
experienced a hangover,
maybe you're underage,
maybe you're just boring,
imagine a headache that
feels like a killer whale
has been dropped on your face.
Now imagine your mouth is a sandy desert.
Now imagine crippling regrets and remorse
and having no idea where
all of your money went.
You're probably thinking to yourself,
why would anybody inflict that
kind of pain upon themselves?
Well, welcome to adulthood.
- You have to drink a ton of
water as you're drinking, okay?
When you're drinking
alcohol drink some water.
Alcohol, some water, and
it will save your ass
from punishment the next day.
Now many of you watching
this are probably going
well Scott, we know this okay?
Could you tell us something
that we don't know?
Could you teach us something
Yes, everybody knows
that you should mix water
into your drinking because
alcohol dehydrates,
but nobody frickin' does it.
How many times have you
gone out with your friends
and just let them drink all night,
without a single drop of water?
I don't want to drink water
because water fills me up, okay?
It makes me bloated.
I just want to, are you out of your mind?
You're going to pay for that the next day.
Your eyes will be over the toilet, okay,
and this is just the worst
feeling in the world right here,
when you're over the
toilet like this you know
and you, you're trying to throw up.
And nothing coming.
It is some painful shit, okay.
That's when god and
you go oh I'm so sorry.
I have sinned, please take
me back into your fold lord.
I will never drink again, pleases Jesus.
You see what I'm saying?
You don't want to be in that situation.
- I actually have some
booze in my shower at home.
Going running, sweating
it out, and having a shot
of chartreuse in the shower.
- Going for a run or sweating it out
and getting all that
crap out of your system
is just fantastic.
- If you go for a run, the
first 10 minutes are horrible.
- The best hangover cure
for me nowadays is a sauna
or a steam room.
- Get out of the house.
Your body starts to work,
your metabolism starts to go.
- When you want to sweat out a
hangover there's two options.
You can either you know have
a whole bunch of spicy food
or you can exercise.
I choose the food.
- [Narrator] Number three, sports drinks.
- Uh, Gatorade me bitch.
- [Narrator] Dehydration caused by alcohol
is essentially what causes your hangover.
Thus, it's important to drink
as many fluids as possible
the following day to
help rehydrate your body.
Sports drinks like Gatorade
are a popular choice
because they help replenish
your body with electrolytes
that it may have lost thanks
to the diuretic effect of alcohol.
- [Announcer] When you're still
a little drunk this morning.
- [Narrator] Stocking
your fridge with Gatorade
before you go out to the bar may save you
a ton of pain in the morning.
- Gatorade not only
quenches your thirst better,
it tastes better too idiot.
- You're, you're, you're
drinking the wrong water.
- All right I know a lot
of people swear by this
but trust me, if you
wake up with a hangover
eating a greasy breakfast
is not the way to go.
In fact, doctors suggest
quite the opposite.
Don't have anything fatty.
Instead, have a breakfast
full of carbs and protein
as that will be much more
soothing for your stomach.
So have a piece of toast with egg,
have some oatmeal, and throw
in some chopped apples,
or have some muskmelon
with some yogurt and honey.
Alcohol tends to drain a lot
of potassium from your body,
so if you're fighting nausea
or a headache eat a banana.
Bananas are chocked full of potassium,
so make yourself a banana
shake and if you like
sweeten it with honey instead of sugar.
It will make you feel much better,
and it will help bring your
blood sugar back to normal.
Cabbages are rich in fiber
and they're full of vitamins
and minerals like sulfur,
potassium, and iodine,
all of which are very good for your body,
especially when you have a hangover.
So try this.
Boil some cabbage and sip on
the cabbage juice all day long.
Trust me, you'll feel much better.
- My hangover cure was charcoal pills,
which are basically these
little pills that are just
like, they are as I said,
it's full of charcoal.
They're supposed to absorb,
this is how they said they work,
they absorb all the
toxins, all the alcohol,
makes it disperse through
your system better.
Take them before you start drinking.
I feel, I feel great.
I don't feel terrible.
I did one shot of tequila.
As the night went on, I asked
for more shots of tequila
in the margarita, which was a bad idea.
But I feel great.
I'd say charcoal pills are confirmed.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
What was the message that you took home
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
in your life or maybe in your business?
Leave down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Andre.
Andre, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really hope you enjoyed the
book and I'm so appreciative
for your support man.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, have an amazing day,
and I'll see you soon.
- I drank this fuckin' soup.
Eat some fuckin' rice,
and eat some seafood,
and now I feel amazing.
- [Narrator] It could be argued that
soup is alcohol's antithesis.
It provides sodium,
water and other nutrients
that alcohol depletes,
and since it can be salty,
you will likely double down on the H20,
which is an added rehydration bonus.
Soup can also help with
digestion and settle down
your stomach if you're feeling nauseas
after a night of heavy drnking.
(upbeat music)
Which is beneficial to people
who may find it too difficult
on their stomachs to eat a meal.
(retching)
A bowl of chicken noodle
soup can go a long way
to helping you feel back to normal.
- Wake up at 3PM, very slowly.
Do everything slowly today.
Reach for your wallet.
That's it, there you go drunky.
Roll over and make sure there's
no one else in bed with you.
If your hangover is truly
horrendous you should be safe.
No matter how sexy you
thought you were being
on the dance floor last night,
you probably scared away
half of the club and
fell over on somebody.
Stare up at the ceiling open mouthed
and contemplate your decisions.
The ones you can remember, anyway.
Get out of bed, slowly.
That's it, upsy daisy.
Remember that you bought some
form of fast food last night
and there's still some left over.
Contemplate eating it.
No, I mean, what?
No, don't do that.
Walk halfway down the hall
and forget what your reason
for getting up was.
And then remember and go to the toilet.
Empty your bladder and maybe your stomach
if it's that kind of hangover.
Now make your way to the
kitchen again, slowly.
Get some form of liquid into your body.
Just about anything will, no, no, no, no,
not that, not that.
Good.
Scientists have said that
the only way to truly recover
from a hangover is to
drink double the amount
that you drank last night but in water.
So be prepared to drain a bath tub.
What are you doing?
Come on.
Now that you've hydrated a little bit,
go and have a seat or a, okay.
Yup, just go do that.
Around this time some
memories of the night before
might start to come back to you,
so let's just stay in this
position for a little while
and let that happen.
But don't fall asleep there.
You still have to eat.
Back to the kitchen.
Grab the first edible
packaged product you see.
Of course you may want to
stock up on what you can now,
'cause this might be the
last time during the day
that you'll be able to
physically leave your bed.
Return to bed with your snacks,
and preferably a laptop.
Now after eating your
weight in carbohydrates
and watching your weight in Netflix,
it's time to go to bed.
So get comfortable,
good night sweet prince.
See you next weekend.